he guys my name is sh welcome back to my
code review Series where we look at
suspicious projects that you guys send
me we're back at it again with the 200
hour 2D game engine because you guys
said you would love for me to keep
looking at this project and considering
we didn't get past the GitHub read me
last time uh yeah I agree we should
probably keep looking at this by the way
if you didn't catch the last video where
we started looking at this project I'll
have it linked up there the goal today
is going to be to actually look at some
code so here we have the project I've
cloned it I've even built it it's ready
to go let's have a look at the project
structure to begin with so we have
engine and GitHub GitHub just has this
uh this diagram that we looked at last
time and then engine is where everything
is so this person mentioned in the email
that it's just a visual studio solution
and project no need to generate anything
you just run this that's not a good way
to organize the build system for your
project in general I have written down
in my list of videos to make to make a
video talking about why that is so I'm
not going to spend too much time
explaining it today generally what you
want to do is use a build system such as
cake or premake I personally highly
recommend premake I much prefer it to
cake and it's certainly a lot easier to
get started if you're looking at a
project like this although actually you
might have some issues with dependencies
if they provide cmake build files and
not premake build files but anyway build
systems are important even if you are
just on a single platform like Windows
the major reason why is because when you
use a build system to generate your
project files you are always going to be
generating the project files that are
specific to your system now that doesn't
mean that it's going to be all absolute
paths like CM likes to do one of the
reasons why I don't like but what I'm
more talking about is like what version
of Visual Studio are you using what
version of the compiler are you using
what version of the windows SDK are you
using how are your dependencies and
environment variables set up what kind
of potential variant of that project are
you trying to generate there's all these
variables that go into how do I want to
build this thing and when you use just
Visual Studio solution project files
whilst that can be a really easy fast
way to get started the flexibility and
configurability is greatly reduced not
to mention that you can only obviously
use visual studio with this project so
that is my first piece of advice now
diving more into this project structure
we have a library directory which has a
bunch of lib files debug release uh
debug just has pdbs interestingly enough
uh and then release has nothing okay so
you're using sfml uh I think that was in
the readme as well wasn't it and then
vus I guess for audio free TI fla sure
this is probably all part of sfml isn't
it I don't know why the debug like are
these debug Library yeah okay so the
debug libraries are here as well so you
can see that one common convention with
Library files is that you'll see like a
d at the end of some libraries and that
just indicates that this is the debug
variant you can also compare just as a
little side note the file sizes so you
can see that the debug is like 7 and 1/2
Meg and then the the the one without the
D which is presumably the release
library is a lot smaller and that's
because debug obviously contains a lot
more information so that you can debug
better and this kind of follows the same
pattern so my suspicion is like I'm not
sure why the pdbs are here I don't even
know if this will work properly because
what the pdbs are by the way is it
stands for programed database and it's
basically a database of a whole bunch of
information that maps symbols to actual
specific source code which is obviously
very very very useful when you're
debugging this is basically how when
you're using a debugger it knows that
the current instruction that it's
executing is specifically this line of
C++ code that you've written without
these files it's not going to know that
because obviously that original source
code goes through a lot of trans
when it gets built into like machine
code that your CPU will actually be
executing and whilst your actual
binaries might still contain named
symbols because if you haven't stripped
any kind of debug information or any
kind of symbols from your binaries you
may still find the actual function names
there it's still going to be difficult
to equate all of the essentially
assembly instructions but assembly
instructions would be the disassembled
machine code because your CPU is
obviously executing the machine code and
not the assembly but nevertheless this
way it lets you equate that machine code
assembly to actual C++ source code which
is very very useful so I don't know if
these being in this directory I don't
know how this happened uh because it
doesn't look like I don't think you're
compiling sfml but that's just something
I noticed something interesting
resources things to add to user po init
yes rotation yes change name okay sure
it's probably some development file just
like a a to-do or something saves icons
font okay sure so we got a bunch of
fonts we' got template okay templates so
this is possibly perhaps when you make a
new project it copies that directory or
something then we have Source directory
okay so let's move on to visual studio
I've already got an open in Visual
Studio here and we'll take a look at it
through here so Sprite engine. CPP let's
give it a run first and we'll see what
this project is but first if you want an
excellent free way to ease into computer
science and learn a whole bunch of mouth
while you're at it then check out
brilliant.org the sponsor of this video
brilliant.org is an amazing website
filled with lots and lots of really high
quality courses on various stem topics
they have a bunch of fun easy to follow
computer science courses that can really
help you if you're having trouble
wrapping your head around what it means
to actually write code and think like a
programmer and in these courses you'll
be learning this stuff in a really
really visual interactive and engaging
way you won't just be watching videos
you'll be asked to actually click on
stuff manipulate it to see how things
work and you'll be constantly quizzed to
make sure that you're actually learning
and retaining the information that's
being taught to you math is also super
important for programming and Brilliant
have this wonderful Everyday Math course
that will ease you into math if you've
never really done it before or you've
never found it easy and their math
courses will follow through all the way
to Advanced topics such as calculus and
again in that fun interactive and
engaging way and the best thing about
brilliant is you can get started for
free they have a 30-day free trial that
you can use to check out all of the
courses on their platform and see if you
like them and if you do brilliant have
been nice enough to offer the first 200
subscribers 20% off an annual membership
huge thank you to brilliant as always
for sponsoring this video okay so we
this is the source code yes we have made
it we are finally looking at actual code
in a code revieww video but if I may
there's already problems when I look
over here there is a single project in
this entire solution in this entire game
engine there is a single project that is
not what I would do I'm hesitant to say
that that is wrong uh like I don't like
using the words right and wrong because
I feel like programming is so subjective
and like to me honestly programming is a
bit of an art form and so if you're an
artist and you come in and you do things
yes they might not be conventional yes
they might not be how everyone else
would do it and yes they might not be
how Professional Engineers with
architect game engines but that might
not be the goal here the goal might be
well I want to do this the way I want to
do this you can't look at someone's
painting and be like no no no that is
wrong like yeah sure they might be able
to use better techniques to achieve
better transfer of the ideas and the
image they have in their mind into this
actual physical medium but they could
always turn around and be like no but
this is what I'm going for and I am
achieving it thank you very much and so
I guess my point is my advice here is
not necessarily this is right this is
wrong and I am the judge that decides at
all it's more so is this something the
chero would do or is this not something
The Cho would do and this is not
something The Cho would do why because
you are blurring the line between game
and engine and the reason why that is
not a good thing to do is because game
does not equal engine does not equal
engine and it's also my diagram just uh
got deleted so game does not equal
engine and it's also the fact that the
relationship between these two is kind
of like well you the engine is going to
be capable of making more than one game
you're going to have multiple games and
then this engine is supposed to be like
the central core platform that these
games are using and so if you just have
the single project it's like okay well
how do I make a game now that is just
the beginning and if we look at how this
is actually used so the main function of
this engine immediately opens a UI
project selector and we open up a
project and then we looks like we start
some kind of instance of the engine we
create like a render window and then we
update the engine this doesn't make any
sense because a game engine is actually
two different applications which again
is why this single project here is just
just makes no sense a game engine at
least this like what I can see from this
code your game engine the way you've
decided to make a game engine is it has
to be two completely different
applications there has to be the editor
which is this like I would like to open
a project this is clearly part of the
editor and so is all of this and then in
Orange we have the engine which is
presumably going to actually run stuff
it could run the editor the editor could
be an application that the engine
supports the editor could be written
entirely using engine runtime features
that's also totally fine but
nevertheless it is still a separate
application and then we have this which
is kind of the core engine or you could
call it the runtime and I see this sort
of design all the time and this is
unfortunately what tends to happen when
someone doesn't understand the full
picture of what it means to build a game
engine which extends to them simply just
not having the experience to know all of
the moving Parts which I don't blame
them because it's it can be quite
complicated to understand what a game
engine is but this is a huge fundamental
issue that I want to try and clear up
here to everyone making a game engine
out there you have to consider the most
important case of how your engine is
going to be used now if you are just
making a little application game engine
you just want to see how they work you
just want to play around with it then
maybe I could see how this approach
could be okay but traditionally a game
engine is made why because we would like
to make a game with it or maybe an
interactive application of some sort so
then if you are making a game engine and
the goal with the game engine is to
produce a game that you will then
distribute and ship out to people who
will play the game that that
conglomerate of people is your primary
user base not the people using the
editor not the people using the game
engine to make the game it's going to be
the players of the game so that is step
one really and that should be at the
back of your mind and probably at the
front of your mind the entire time that
you're building a game engine it's what
is the experience like for someone who
plays this game and so obviously if we
just look at this main function here the
player of the game is not going to be
presented with a UI project select
to be like oh yeah I want to load this
project no that's what the editor is for
that's what the development team uses
and furthermore not when they're playing
the game or testing the game but when
they're actually opening the editor in
order to build or develop the game now
this is the only solution file that is
in this project because as I'm looking
at this I'm thinking well maybe this is
specifically the editor but see the
thing is that still doesn't make sense
because even if this solution was the
editor and Sprite engine is that's the
editor part of it it's in a single
project which is again why this project
situation doesn't make sense because
that core engine is going to lend itself
to the game which you ship and also all
of the development tools such as the
editor because obviously the editor
needs to be able to use the engine in
order to you know like build your scenes
and run them and do all of that stuff
that is generally how game engins work
these days it's the what you see is what
you get wizzywig form of editing and
that involves you having like a viewport
inside your editor that is using the
engine's core and the engine's run time
to present an image that is a perfect
reflection of what the final product
will be like now that wasn't always the
case in fact even in 2015 2016 when I
worked at EA on the mobile engine team
developing an engine called Osiris which
would be used to ship many many games
but in 2015 we were focusing our efforts
on supporting the game team that would
ship Need for Speed No Limits the editor
for Osiris and the editor for well that
game that they used was a completely
Standalone application that in fact did
not use the core I mean from memory like
it may have used bits of it but what you
saw in the viewport I don't know if I
have any screenshots saved anywhere I
don't know if I'd be allowed to share
them anyway but the rendering of like
the racetrack that you were editing
would be completely fabricated like it
had no lighting it was just models
around and one of my biggest projects
that year was actually to in light Maps
so that the team could not see a flatly
lit version of the track especially cuz
a lot of this game took place at night
but we were kind of stream in those
light map textures as they were being
generated by a thirdparty light map
generator so yes it I mean that that
isn't even that long ago but there the
editor is a completely sine application
it simply edits data files that are that
level and then the core engine the run
time when you load the game and you play
it it loads those files from disk that
have been produced by a completely
separate editor application and that's
how you actually see it for the first
time in game how it would look to the
player that's obviously a very slow
system for iterating it's much better to
just look at exactly you know what you
see is what you get to look at the final
finished product twig the lighting
however you want tweak everything
however you want hit play You're
instantly playing it inside that editor
application that's the dream and so
that's strongly like what I would be
doing here and the core takeaway from
this that would enable that to happen is
this Shar code base that has to be
shared between the game that you ship
out that is the runtime application of
the game and also this editor tooling
that uses this engine now it doesn't
have to use the engine as a platform to
make the editor application if you know
what I mean so in this case you might be
picturing the editor as really just
being a game and it's just it happens to
be a game with lots of UI that can you
know is used to edit and actually make
games that's certainly viable that's
something you could do but this editor
could be made with an entirely different
you know UI platform or something like
for example it could even use C WPF
which would kind of restrict it to being
Windows only it could use cute or QT it
could use IM which is maybe
something that you wouldn't have in
either the core engine or like in the
game that you ship at all but even if
it's written in C and it's in a
completely different language it can
still use that C++ engine to render the
images that you see and to you know
process the assets and the game data and
do all of that stuff so that is the
fundamental problem with what we are
looking at today and specifically in my
opinion and in my experience a major
tell of the inexperience of someone
who's writing this because the first
thing I would expect to see is this is
the runtime that plays the game not
necessarily yeah this is the applic this
is the this is the game engine
application and it's really just an
editor okay now should we try running
this in
release
okay well there goes the oh don't worry
it doesn't have a build system just open
the visual studio solution and run it
does debug work okay debug does actually
work so here's debug uh this is what it
looks like we can do open or create I
guess we should try and create G this is
so annoying I really dislike it when
people make their own file dialogues I
think you should always use the native
file dialogue for whatever platform
you're using so if you're using Windows
you know just use this because you know
why because you have all of your like
saved pins here you have all of your
drives here I can click here and I can
paste in paths I can just paste in a
full path of a file here and hit open
I'm used to this conventional design why
Implement something worse where I have
to navigate from my Root Drive which I
can't even Collapse by the way and also
I can only see the C drive what the heck
where are all of my other
drives all right this is enough for one
video thank you guys for watching hope
you enjoyed this uh code review we
didn't really get past the first file
but we did run the project I'm looking
forward to trying to make a new project
with this seeing like what the editor
and the actual game engine can do cuz
again 2,000 hours I have high hopes for
this if you would like to see more
definitely let me know in the comment
section below and hit the like button if
you enjoyed this video and don't forget
to check out brilliant link will be in
the description below I'll see you guys
next time goodbye